foreign
has zero time for body shaming and
neither do we
[Music]
making jaws drop at the Golden Globes
Selena stunned in her Valentino dress
while Selena was definitely a winner on
the red carpet in our eyes certain
online trolls decided to criticize her
look and Selena said not today during an
Instagram live with her sister the
actress addressed the negative online
chatter I'm a little bit big right now
because I enjoyed myself during the
holidays I mean
right
sorry baby first step towards getting
over a breakup drop a diss track oh and
uh have that song Break records in her
fiery new song visit rap music session
number 53 Shakira is seemingly taking
aim at her ex Gerard Piquet and his new
girlfriend with Savage lyrics like I'm
worth two 22 year olds you traded a
Ferrari for a twin go you traded a Rolex
for a Casio
the song now has over a hundred million
views making the track the most watched
Latin song in YouTube's history and
according to Daily Mail Shakira has been
listening to her song on full blast
while decorating her balcony with a
witch yep you heard that right a witch
that views her ex-mother-in-law's
property
[Music]
could Miley's new self-love Anthem be
about her ex-husband Liam Hemsworth well
fans seem to think so hint number one
the track dropped on Liam's birthday
last Friday two eagle-eyed fans have
noticed that Miley's song resembles
Bruno Mars's When I Was Your Man a song
that Liam reportedly dedicated to my
list
[Music]
and three it's possible Miley is copying
the suit Liam War at The Avengers
endgame Premiere in 2019 where he
reportedly told her to behave Miley has
yet to confirm the fan theories